foreign
Meetup it's kind of weird with the
microphone
uh yes exactly I'll try to stick with
the mic so you might expect slightly a
slightly different setup than what we
actually ended up with because we
intended to have Omarion severe here
tonight uh from from hogging face but uh
yeah tonight Leandro joined us because
there was a personal emergency but I'm
very excited for for leandro's talk and
also extremely grateful for him stepping
in on such a short notice and um uh yeah
to to summarize what we'll expect is uh
first to talk by Christian Bourgeois a
colleague of mine about training in
Python and deploying anywhere and anyhow
we will have roughly a 30 minute talk
there will be 10 minutes of time for
your questions and respective answers
and after that Leandro will talk about a
big code a
um yeah Mighty open source project
started at hogging face
um with that I would also
uh say let's let's let's slowly get
started uh with the talks and uh
question is first up and he has a
background in experimental uh particle
physics he did research uh in and with
CERN for quite a while and if you're one
of these people like myself who
sometimes get confused about the the
Blurred boundaries between data science
data engineering and software
engineering Christian is your guy
because he's done it all
he did all of these roles in many
different companies uh and and he knows
what's going on
since almost two years now he works at
quonco and in the for the past year and
a half roughly speaking has been
following his passion when it comes to
building data science tooling with a
clear and short path towards production
in particular he's been focusing on the
Onyx tooling and ecosystem of which he
will tell us no more so give a warm
welcome to Christian
[Applause]
thank you very much
hmm
did this just
sorry I see different slides here then
uh you guys see over there
yeah that looks about right perfect
right that's that also work yes
apparently
okay well in any case I'm sure this uh
will go over smoothly so uh yes as Kevin
actually just announced I will actually
talk about Onyx but it is hidden behind
the somewhat cryptic uh talk title train
and python deploy anywhere and anyhow so
what I really want to drive home with
this talk is essentially that well it's
a python conference to start with so we
do like to train our models in Python
but sometimes that's a little
restrictive in the deployment so it's
not that we don't want to deploy in
Python necessarily but we want to
divorce the training part from the
deployment part and uh
I want to show you a way to actually
achieve this where essentially yeah
you are you have maximum freedom in
deployment without compromising how you
actually train your models all right so
this is the outline for this talk so
first I'm going to drill in a little bit
try to analyze okay why is it actually
so difficult sometimes or oftentimes to
actually deploy our trained machine
learning models
um and um
whatever serves our our particular
production use case and then as Kevin
already sort of uh uh gave the answer
away the big the big surprise the answer
will be on X Onyx is a open source
standard I will obviously go into more
details there
to directly work with it might be a bit
cumbersome so we actually invested in
some tooling we wrote a library called
spox spox and I will actually really
show how you can actually write your
inference logic using this framework to
actually then yeah get your model into
this Onyx format and then take it to
deployment well and then lastly of
course what what kind of talk would be
complete without some kind of summary
all right let's jump into it just one
question about the audio is it going in
and out or does it only seem for me okay
cool thanks
all right
yeah as mentioned what actually makes
deploying our models difficult at times
uh let's let's sort of walk a little
through the lifetime the life
cycle of our model so what is shown here
is like a small schematic of course we
we start
uh with some kind of python environment
we have some sort of dependencies and
that's what the the little box at the
bottom is and then we start at the very
beginning of a project we start with
some
data exploration feature engineering etc
etc and at this stage of the project
python with its quick
iteration speed it's it's virtually
unbeatable it's super flexible super
nice to work with I guess I don't I'm
literally preaching to the choir here in
this setting and then
of course at some point hopefully your
project actually matures you're building
something and you actually start to
train stuff
so you take some data it sort of well
it's it's a bit hand waving the
schematics to be honest but like I want
to sort of say the data is somewhat
outside of your training environment you
take it in for your training step you
train it now you have some weights and
now your model is essentially this
pretty complex pretty large
object residing in the memory of your
python process now that's a bit
unfortunate because of course that is
usually not where we deploy our models
so usually we train on some machine at
some point and then we have to serialize
it and then we have to train it again
then we have to actually load it
whatever artifact we have and then
deploy from there so that would look
something like this one recommended way
to do it according to the scikit-learn
documentation would be okay you have
your pipeline it's all trained you just
pickle it and that's your artifact and
then who here has work with pickle
also great engagement things
um yeah so the problem with pickle of
course it actually does a fantastic job
of like serializing your state it puts
it into
a binary file but it's not
self-contained by any stretch of the
imagination essentially you have to like
recreate your training environment and
this is the reason why I'm sort of
having this schematic here like your
artifact alone is worth next to nothing
because the actual Logic for your
inference is not in the pickle file it
is
a environment that you have to provide
whenever you load your pickle file so
that's a bit unfortunate essentially you
just have to hope for the best that
whenever you load it it still works with
your environments all right yeah and
then of course like based on that if
that is sort of essentially your
workflow to actually get your model and
take it to deployment then well it may
or may not work so what may or may not
work let's take a closer look
so we have our pickle and
yeah if we now want to distribute our
model we want to take it somewhere else
again
we have our weights and the pickle but
we don't have the logic so wherever
whatever we ship we actually have to
ship the definition for the environment
along with the pickle file
again this is this is not necessarily A
unsolvable Problem by any stretch of the
imagination but it actually makes it
less defined less standardized how are
we how are we going to like communicate
this information how are we going to
take it to deployment
and then sort of not necessarily
orthogonal problems to that of course if
we want to Archive a model let's say we
want to keep a model around for
for years okay if we just keep the
pickle file again maybe some security
problems come in we have essentially
Frozen dependencies not good or another
scenario would be okay we have two
models trained at different points in
time now we want to compose them into a
bigger model
maybe the dependencies change maybe we
can't really use the pickle without
friction anymore sad or something maybe
a little more out of the Beaten Track
but definitely something we have on the
radar is okay we have some particular
intellectual property that sort of goes
into the training process how we
actually built the model that we don't
necessarily want to expose to whoever is
actually deploying the model and if we
have a pickle then it's very easy for
information to either sort of exit
accidentally slip in because it's
difficult to separate and it's very
generic very automatic or the other way
around sometimes it's yeah it just it
has to be there just because we have to
actually provide the again rebuild the
training environment not unsolvable but
cumbersome to solve with the existing
tooling and then
well using piccol of course still sort
of ties us to python
sometimes we love python yeah but
sometimes the performance really is not
not that great especially if we want to
go like multi-threaded or something so
it would be great to be able to actually
execute our pipeline in something a
little more
performant and then taking a step
further and maybe also something that
sort of alludes to the title of the talk
yeah well maybe we want to train our
model our cycle learn pipeline for
example in Python but then when we
actually deploy it we might not even
have python available on that particular
platform so let's say you actually want
to deploy your model on the edge let's
say in the web browser using webassembly
or something then of course if it's like
a based on a pickle like how are you
going to ship that in a web browser it's
not going to work you're gonna somehow
get out of that so now this is slide
number four and I am slowly but surely
hopefully motivating you that actually
the status quo of just pickling your
trained models not that great
so yeah why why is it actually so hard I
mean we have been shipping software for
like decades we have been versioning
software we have been archiving software
what is the problem with machine
learning and like oh like why is it so
much harder to take it to deployment
it's not that it's just bigger it's
actually it's something else so let's
look at my little schematics here again
let's look at the use case for
a non-machine learning case
we have our source codes we compile it
let's say it's some C we compile it with
GCC it doesn't matter we get an artifact
out of it and when we now actually
execute this artifact we don't need GCC
the compiler to actually run the
artifact we sort of get an artifact that
fundamentally is outside of the
compilation environment or training
environment whatever you want to call it
and yeah as a reminder this is what we
have we have our training environment
then we have this big Pipeline and at
the end we get an artifact that we can
write to this but it's fundamentally
tied to the training environment so the
Odysseus
thing that I want to do is this I want
to introduce some
vague step into the pipeline uh Magic
and now we get an artifact and the
artifact is not any longer tied to the
training environment it's outside of the
trying environment like if you like we
have our train model it's in the python
process and now we compile it into
something that is self-sustain a self
self-contained and independent of
whatever we just had
all right and then again the name was
mentioned a few times that sort of
artifact here is uh Onyx on XS the name
is a little misleading it's open neural
network exchange but technically it's
not only for neural networks it's for
you it's and also it's not only for the
regressor it's for your entire Pipeline
with feature engineering and everything
so uh think of it just as a file format
to actually store your trained model
period like your train pipeline not like
it's all encompassing ideally all right
so let's motivate this a little further
like why why would something like this
be great so we could for example have a
scenario where we train maybe our model
in pi torch and we export to Onyx we
train our model using our cycle learn
pipeline we export it to Onyx or
tensorflow whatever
and then we have this Universal
standardized file format and then from
there
doesn't really matter where the model
came from we can actually deploy it
and I'm going to show an example what
this deployment would actually look like
in a second but essentially usually it
always works this way we have a
particular piece of software called a
runtime that takes this binary Onyx
model definition loads it gets it ready
for inference and then we throw input
data at it and we get essentially the
result back and uh now here honestly
it's not particularly mature yet but of
course given the oops given the venue I
couldn't help myself but actually put
the latest addition to the Onyx family
here on the slide a project by Google
that also essentially
provides one of those runtimes honestly
I have not tried it yet but it's out
there
all right let's take a closer look what
it actually means to sort of deploy a
model like that all right
the common run time or the most commonly
used runtime is actually a project
maintained by Microsoft aptly called
Onyx runtime
and on the next slide I'm going to show
how it works and for that sort of the
model let's say the thing in the middle
is the Onyx model.onics file okay so in
deployment it would look like something
like this you import
you import your runtime whatever in this
case again the Onyx runtime but could be
Jax runtime or your own you create your
session essentially you load the model
it gets ready at this point you don't
know necessarily data yet and this is
reusable
and then you have this well this little
wrapper to give it a more explicit uh
presentable API uh where essentially you
give some inputs you throw it at the
session and you get your predictions out
that's it
and again as you can see on the slide
there you don't export import scikit
learn or tensorflow or whatever this is
technically everything you need you can
completely forget about however you
build your model it's completely
independent and it doesn't necessarily
need to be python this is a C plus plus
project with Java bindings and etc etc
all right
oh nice all nice
but maybe the elephant in the in the
room the magic step it's great okay so
there is some kind of some kind of file
format if we get there okay everything
is fantastic our deployment will be fast
it will be simple it will be
maintainable great everything we have to
do is just some some magic so what is
what is the name of the game if we sort
of want to do this so again we we have
our model it sits as a complex object in
our python process memory and now we
want to compile it or export it or
okay essentially what we want to do is
we want to take our inference logic and
the info and the state necessary for the
inference so not only the source code
and not only the weights both together
into this Onyx file
uh now that sounds a little daunting but
honestly it's it's really actually not
that hard
uh but before before we actually look at
the details of how to do it let's look a
little deeper at what actually on excess
all right so
first and foremost Onyx itself is really
just a standard it's not an
implementation or anything it just
defines
how to store your trained Pipeline and
it does that essentially by saying okay
your model is is just a computational
technically strongly typed not that
important for this particular occasional
computational directed acyclic graph
and to look at it in a little more
detail okay so the edges of the graph
are essentially tensor so X is an input
to our model then we have edges
which sort of just show where
our tensors go
um and then we have nodes they are
operators so for example add Mobile Mad
mole Etc and then again it's not only
the logic that we want to store we want
to store logic and state so it's very
important to sort of note okay there's
also a place where our state our weights
reside so for example in this example
here we have a bunch of constant nodes
that take essentially values Etc and
yeah
put them into the graph wherever they
are needed
what this graph is doing is actually not
that important right now and then of
course all of this would be somewhat
insufficient if there is not actually
also a definition of what the individual
nodes are supposed to do so what the
semantics of an at node for example is
an add node takes two tensors of type T
and produces a tensor of type T all
right so that is that is it that it's
just a standard
now of course directly sort of writing a
graph structure like that for your
inference that would be quite
quite cumbersome to directly to it
so instead we actually take an
abstraction that actually works really
really well so on X you can forget about
sort of it being like a graph or
something in the background at the end
it just defines an API of just another
tensor Library just like numpy or
whatever it's just a tensor Library API
and what we've done uh with with our
project where we invested quite heavily
into called spocks it's essentially a
way that exposes this entire standard in
something that looks rather familiar to
numpy for example
so it makes it much much easier to work
with and to directly Define our graph
all right so
how would this look in practice
how would we express our logic in this
nice framework spocks this box again is
just a wrapper around onyx
all right so before looking at it
directly let's look at
uh what it would look like to have a
simple linear regression using numpy all
right we have
some uh well some familiar Imports here
of course and then we have our linear
regression it takes some input tensor
here some weights some coefficients and
some intercept does a matrix
multiplication adds together Returns the
values great now this is very concise
looks very pretty but just to sort of
make it more explicit we could also
write it in a bit more verbose fashion
where we explicitly spell out what
operations are being done so we have our
ads our mat mole yeah that's actually it
all right and now uh spocks is just
another tensor Library Onyx is just
another API for something like that
except while numpy is eager the values
are always available
in Onyx when we build the graph we don't
actually know the values yet so it's
fundamentally lazy but it's the same the
same deal so let's look what the same
thing actually would look like if we if
we do it in Spock so Onyx so the first
thing
okay we hand around the values
technically in the standards doesn't
always need to be a tensor so it's a VAR
is a variable it doesn't really matter
so much just some lazy variable
and then we operators are versioned in
the standard so we're explicitly saying
like oh okay let's take version 18 input
it is up just like before we had NP for
numpy here similar syntax similar deal
and then here's our linear regression we
take our
lazy input we have some actual state
that we want to bake into the graph and
now here we create those constant nodes
we move this date into like nodes and
then here we get some yeah we do the the
ADD and the multiply and we get a lazy
value out but the lazy value remembers
where it came from you can build it's
sort of the the graph that led to it and
you actually have the values that you
need baked in
all right now at this point I had a
small update to my slides with a nice
meme of like okay well but who builds
actually a graph using three functions
like this not a graph sorry who builds a
model using three functions like this
usually you would want to have it in
something more composable so PSI
scikit-learn for example of course you
have like individual classes you compose
them in Pipelines
um but the important thing here to note
is there is zero Magic on this slide
it's just plain python you're just
passing around lazy values
and that means we can actually build
just the same abstraction
uh
that where we essentially have classes
that Define small subgraphs and then we
compose them in our Pipeline and stuff
so for example we could have a class
for our linear regressor explicitly we
initiated with some State
or the trained model we move it in here
and then for predict yeah we essentially
have the same the same deal that we had
on the previous slide we just move this
date into the graph and we have these
individual classes and yeah then what we
would need is some kind of way to
actually look up okay this is the
converter class for this and this class
I want to convert so for example a
converter function
you get your train model you look up the
thing you want and return it and then
with that
you can essentially build like pipelines
and you can
get the same composability that you
would expect from scikit-learn you can
get it like essentially using this
framework now
uh the astute listener might have
noticed that essentially I have been
pushing around like one important part
namely where does the very first bar
come from so far it was all just
functions I showed you so let's actually
complete the entire setup let's actually
build this Onyx file uh so here's
essentially a full full example we would
have our Pipeline
with in this case two trivial steps we
fitted to some kind some some data
and then we have our converters let's
say they live in this Library using the
protocol as I've showed before
we create the very very first input so
Onyx is Type to strongly typed so we
have to say Okay the inputs are for
example float64 they have this in this
shape so we don't necessarily have to
say the exact number but we have to say
the rank and then okay please convert my
train pipeline
and now I give it the daisy value X so Y
is the lazy output and now I built the
graph here so essentially using these
inputs and those output just give me the
entire graph and give me the binary file
that sort of fits with it or rather the
more the Proto buff and then just save
it into a file
so that's it I'm sorry I know this was a
lot of code but I hope you sort of get
the general gist okay uh what you can do
is you train your model and then you
have to
with the current state of the tooling
you have to re
you have to duplicate the inference
logic and move the state into this
little graph you're defining with this
lazy framework now I just said the word
code duplication and it probably gave a
bunch of shutters down some spines here
in the room and that is of course a
little sad
uh uh we don't like code duplication so
let me give you a quick Outlook of where
the ecosystem which is fairly new and
still maturing but it's it's maturing
quickly actually where the ecosystem is
headed so
spocks is just another tensor Library it
just happens to be lazy but it's just
another tensor Library just like numpy
or Jax or tensorflow and I think you get
the gist but I'm gonna be labor it a
little more
you get it it's a bit it's getting a
little crazy so the problem is the
problem is of if you write a framework
like so I could learn
it should arguably be agnostic to
whatever underlying framework is so
there is initiative in the ecosystem to
standardize
uh these tensor libraries with a common
API so that essentially all of them have
like a restricted like little sub-module
where you have like an array that
supports a smaller API but a standard as
API Cipher so that it just works so you
could for example take scikit-learn and
they're they already actually started
with the implementation following the
standard that scikit-learn becomes
agnostic to the actual library that
you're using and that would mean it
doesn't matter whether you throw a numpy
area edit or as box based array it would
have just essentially traced the exact
code that exists in cycle learn upstream
and at the end for number you get a
number array first box you get some lazy
Orthodontics you would get some lazy
array back
and essentially would just trace this
the entire code upstream and you
wouldn't need to write converters
anymore it would sort of just just just
work beautifully
yes so that is we are not quite there
yet we are building Tooling in this
regard to essentially reduce the code
duplication but at this point uh it's it
works and it's actually quite usable and
I'm now actually already taking a few
steps for my summary slide so
let's put it
all together again okay
spocks and or slash Onyx what it
actually does is you have your trained
model you compile it or whatever you
want to call it into some self-contained
binary file that knows everything you
don't need any of the training
environment all you need is this one
binary file
and
once you have it you get very nice very
clean very efficient deployment where
you can update your dependencies as you
please it gives you a lot of freedom
very nice
it is definitely ready for production
use we're actually using it in
production for more than a year and a
half now very successfully it actually
gave us a 100x boost in latency which
was
very needed actually and
um
lastly maybe and maybe I should have now
changed this to Google given the venue
but Onyx really does have large
corporate backing actually so it's not
some project or someone in the basement
not that that is bad with open source
technically but it actually has already
large corporate backing so we have
Microsoft on board we clearly have
Google showing some interest Etc so it's
not a project that is going to go away
um yeah and lastly this has really
become over the last two years that
we've invested into this technology at
Quantico it has become a key technology
for us at Quantico we're using it again
we're using it in production and we're
really planning on making this more of a
Cornerstone of future projects that we
engage with that this more or less maybe
becomes our standard to actually store
and deploy our models yes uh so if you
want to know more about it I would
really recommend going to this little
framework we built as box uh not because
I want to make advertisement for it also
but I think it's actually the best entry
point to actually get you into the
ecosystem and it has good documentation
so check it out and at this point I
would also remiss to say one of the main
author of this library is actually Jaco
pahowski uh
and uh very very talented guy did it in
his internship largely actually and uh I
also stole some of the slides so credit
to him as well where creditors do and
yeah please let me know if you have some
questions that's it
[Applause]
yes
use those
thank you
hello hey
um thank you for the presentations I'm
really excited to see your developing
easy to use API on top of honest
um a couple questions in terms of the
API it reminds me quite a lot of
tensorflow 1 orphiano
um could you explain a little bit kind
of like what is the differences between
kind of like those older library because
sometimes I feel like
the tensor Library feel kind of like
moving
moving towards eager kind of eager style
executions like Jack's pie Torch
tensorflow 2 and the Paradigm of more
lazy tensor feels a little bit outdated
but I'm I'm really happy to see kind of
like it has a comeback
uh maybe there's a because my
understanding of Jax is also that a lot
of it is essentially you try to
build
something in advance to then be like
very efficient once you actually sort of
see the data but
uh be that as it may I think the main
difference really is and
the point is the standardization uh yes
there are X there are ways to express
your
inference logic in tensorflow or Pi
torch in a in a similar way I would
actually call it lazy uh
and then export it into some binary file
but the problem then of course it's
still fundamentally Pi torch it's still
fundamentally tensorflow that might or
may not be a problem but it's not
necessarily standardized and with Onyx
and you essentially have like one open
standard a specification of what an ad
operator is supposed to do what a
convolution is supposed to do what uh
true or zombie regressor is supposed to
do and that I think is really the the
difference that now instead of actually
having to deploy your model using
tensorflow for example everybody is free
to like essentially just write a runtime
that follows the specification and you
can essentially write a runtime without
caring about the training part at all so
it's actually not that difficult
does that answer your question what what
the exactly the the value would be the
value in my opinion is standardization
and therefore divorcing the training and
the deployment
I agree with the standardization I guess
my questions was more around the
comparison of API features but just a
kind of like a sinus respond to your
questions as to your answers is that
um it essentially is uh in kind of like
a standalized intermediate
representation right I I guess I can
make the same argument of oh maybe I
would just
I don't have a kind of like what Jax is
doing have a Jack's PR that have have
that middle layer being SLA instead or
llvm instead of honest
he yes uh
I mean again this is not the only way
you could technically get to like an
intermediate representation yes so in
that regard yes there are other
immediate represent intermediate
representation yes and that it's again a
slightly different API well a bit
unfortunate but again there are like
these uh
pushes in the community to actually
settle on like a standard that you can
just sort of wrap and then essentially
you can write agnostic libraries and I
think this will be
a bright future
thanks
um my question is tomorrow I have a team
meeting and my boss will ask me
sure that sounds nice but which pain is
bigger like making it run without Onyx
or actually the conversion to it and I
think it's that I mean I don't like pain
so I I will
I would choose the Lesser pain in this
sense
um what can I tell him yeah I mean I can
kind of tell you uh how we got to this
so and when we actually got to this the
tooling was
great
it's much better now so how we got to it
like it at one go we essentially our
sales purchase okay we built like really
good like machine learning models and
this is our pitch to our clients like
you get the best models you can possibly
get on the market now we did that and
the model we were building was
essentially required for like some web
API service with strict latency
requirements and the problem was okay
when everything was said and done we had
a fantastic model statistically speaking
but it was way too slow the latency was
just way too like a factor of 10 uh
above what we actually needed and at
that point of course we had like two
options we could either Backtrack on our
pitch and like ah well okay let's let's
boil down the model and not make it that
awesome anymore statistically speaking
but meet the latency requirements Ah
that's a difficult pitch or we somehow
after pulling all the tricks in the book
actually somewhere find this Factor 10
latency Improvement and back then our
pipeline was essentially based around
pandas and a scikit-learn like Pipeline
and well the boiling down models was
really not a way we wanted to go so
somehow we needed to get this faster and
the idea was okay if we can convert our
pipeline into a nonx pipeline
everything should work out so then
actually that was a lot of work because
the tooling was really not there yet at
that point and that's sort of why we
actually invested in it and with the
Lessons Learned we built this box
Library
um and yeah ultimately we got a factor
of 100 latency so sometimes or then like
about two years ago
it was okay we really needed to get this
faster and this was like the only like
obvious way we we also didn't want to
tell like the
data scientists to use a completely
different tool or we didn't want to go
down a route where they built a model
and now we have to like translate the
model and manually write it in like some
compiled language every single time with
like months of work that's also not
feasible so we came up essentially also
with this way of like essentially
writing converters for each of the
classes so that it's just composable and
now we had actually a point where if
there was a model update it's no problem
actually building the Onyx model just
runs in CI it doesn't matter if there's
like a new class somewhere or like
something called rearranged or whatever
just automatically always serializes to
Onyx model so
at this point honestly the tooling got
much better the pain is not that great
and I did not mention it actually
explicitly but if you actually build a
scikit-learn pipeline
okay my slides are gone there is
actually a like if you look at this box
documentation there are some projects
already out there that essentially give
you converters for scikit-learn and you
can wrap them sort of with box because
yeah in my humble opinions just a much
cleaner API so you can actually get a
lot of stuff already sort of pre-made by
other open source projects so honestly
the pain is not that big as you might
imagine
thanks
there was one more but
if we have the time yes uh yeah hello
thanks uh always love standardization
and so just for the speed up itself so I
assume that then comes from a better run
time than the initial training
environment what kind of developments
are there you know from also
compiled run times collaborations with
rust or whatever these kind of
developments
I would love to have a runtime and rust
uh who wouldn't uh no why why is it
faster okay so in this particular case
it was latency and our pipeline had
pundas and I don't know if you ever sort
of made some Benchmark with the latency
of pandas but it's uh
could be better
um so by actually just not using pandas
and essentially just having something
and the runtime is completely in in C
plus plus so on that account actually it
is very good performance to start with
and then on the other hand
Partners is not necessarily a difficult
opponent to beat when it comes to
latency and now of course
you know your mileage may vary like the
runtime is actually always good you you
have better possibilities for actually
optimizing also like for multi-threading
for example the runtime may know just
like oh okay your graph is completely
separable in like two completely
independent subgraphs and then of course
they can easily be run multi-threaded
even though they may have hundreds of
nodes each uh and that's much better
performance of course than if you were
to for example try to multi-thread
within a single node
um so stuff like that you have better
optimization possibilities and then
depending on what exactly you look at
your benchmark are you looking at
throughput are you looking at latency
Etc but at this point I think it's
pretty safe to say it's
equal or better than just the standard
numpy or Partners based stuff always
thank you
[Applause]
with that we will then get to our second
talk by Leandro and Leandro graduated
from eth majoring in physics not too
long ago he's gathered experience in
several data science positions and he's
also been a lecturer at the banner for
Schuler uh you might know him from his
very popular uh publication with
O'Reilly that he co-authored with his
co-worker Lewis called natural language
processing with Transformers
and for the past two years uh he's been
at hogging face and among many other
things he's been the creator of TRL the
Transformer reinforcement learning
library and he's also been the lead of
big code or which we will he will tell
us more now so give a warm welcome to
Leandro
thanks a lot for having me
awesome so I'm going to talk a bit about
Bitcoin big code has been a project I've
been working on for the past nine months
at least publicly a little bit of
preparation before that and the goal of
big code is really to build large
language models for code but that in the
open and in a hopefully responsible way
um
talk a little bit about three things
first if you want to train a large
language model you need a data set
and we built one called the stack
probably like in in the life cycle of
our project that was like 80 percent of
all the effort going into the data set
and then the training itself was much
shorter actually
um finally we trained uh star coder
which is a large language model for code
it's competitive with some of or with
all of the the open source code model
and also with like several of the closed
ones
uh finally I want to talk a little bit
about scaling laws uh just to motivate a
bit why people start training smaller
models for longer there's actually like
a reason uh theoretical reason uh why
you can do that
so let's get started with the pick code
community so big code operates as a open
research collaboration it's led by
hunting face and servicenow as kind of
like the two institutions sponsoring the
compute to actually train models but
it's open to anybody who wants to join
so if you want to work on a large
language follower code you can go to the
website and and join our slack Channel
um when I made the slide it was 500
participants I think now we're closer to
a thousand and you can see like the
diversity of people working on it by the
on the star-coded paper where you can
see like there are people from research
institutions from big companies but also
like from from random small companies or
just freelancer
and that this is one part that made the
the project quite exciting it's a very
diverse group of people that comes
together and builds language models
when we started a project we found that
like actually training large language
models for code is not only a technical
challenge not only about like how do you
build a large data set and how do you
get the compute and the training set up
to train them there are also a lot of
like governance questions
um one question is around consent to all
the people who wrote the code that
you're training on consent to you using
it are you allowed to to train models on
such code
their privacy risks they're training on
huge amounts of data there is like a lot
of people at some point in life
accidentally committed a password
we train on those and you can quite
easily prompt language models to to give
you passwords by just typing password
equals and it will spit out a few
few passwords so we don't want to have a
model that like enables people to do bad
things so that's one concern and then
also concern about security one thing is
to have kind of restrict people using
your models to do bad things for example
writing malware but something that also
quite often happens is that
we train on a lot of code from the past
and there might have been like a lot of
known vulnerabilities these days that we
trained on and these models might
regenerate them
so there are lots of questions that are
not purely technical around language
models that we at least to some degree
try to address
there is also questions around like why
you want to build an open language model
and not only close ones
there are lots of issues around
reproducibility for most closed language
models we don't know exactly what
architecture was used we don't know the
training data that went in
so there's an issue of like scientific
reproducibility but also as like someone
who might have contributed data to the
training you have no way of checking
right you don't know if your data was
used to train chat GPT
and one issue that we face because we
wanted to expand the space of evaluation
of language models for code
we don't know what the other language
models were trained on so we don't know
if the benchmarks that we were adding
and the pieces of code that went into
those benchmarks were actually in the
pre-training data of some other models
does contaminating them
then there are also some issues around
models that are only available through
through apis that limit the research if
you can't really dig into the model it
limits the things that you can do so
I listed a few points like it makes it
hard for safety and Alignment it makes
it hard to like really look at like how
do the models generate the things that
they generate and why and also it's very
hard for or impossible for people to
build their own like variations of it by
using for example new methods like Laura
to fine-tune these models on your own
data
so these are things that are limiting
and if we develop language models in the
open it makes them much easier
I don't know if the slides gonna get
available for everybody but I listed
like a lot of links of like the
resources how we try to address various
aspects like I don't have time to go
through like all of them but should give
you a little bit of taste of like the
thought that went into like various
aspects
but now let me get to the data set so
before we start training a large
language model we need a large data set
and most data sets that were available
at the time when we started and still
are not large enough to train large
language models or not diverse enough so
we started building our own data set we
call the stack
that we released like six months ago
and the stack is a publicly available
data set and everybody can download it
it's 6.4 terabytes of code we only use
permissively license code from GitHub we
have around 360 programming languages
and we have tools to do data inspections
so you can check what kind of data is in
the data set and you can also check
whether you are in the data set so you
can put in your GitHub username and you
can see the repositories that went into
the stack and if you don't like to be in
the stack you can opt out there's an
opt-out form
so how do you build a six terabyte data
set this is our data pipeline or a
simplification of our data pipeline
um and we started with GitHub archive
which is an archival effort for for
GitHub and we use their database to
query all the GitHub repositories that
exist and then the next thing we did was
git cloning for three months on a
cluster
there's not really a way around that
so after three months what we ended up
with was a repository with 130 million
repositories uh 50 billion files and 100
terabyte of data
we then filtered that data set a bit for
file extensions we didn't include any
binary format for example we limited a
bit like the the largest uh files to to
keep things sane and then
um where we actually lost most of the
data is when we filtered it for
permissive licenses if you look at the
license Distribution on GitHub there are
only three licenses or three types
there's a Apache 2 there's MIT and
there's no license and everything else
is like a few percent Maybe
so when you remove the no license data
you go from 69 terabytes to six
terabytes
we did some data ablations we wanted to
figure out like if you train a language
models you want to train it on high
quality code and I have a lot of
repositories that are not high quality
code so we want to figure out how could
we exclude a low quality code and we did
some ablations where we filtered for
GitHub Stars we looked at code to
comments ratios if it's only comments or
no comments at all probably it's not
great code
we also looked at how efficient the
tokenizer was on different files to
figure out if there may be hashes in in
those files that we don't want to train
on
what we found is nothing really matters
the only the one thing that makes things
versus filtering for GitHub Stars
that makes the model worse the only
thing that makes it better is nearly
duplication so we which is nice it's
language agnostic we can apply to the
whole data set we don't need to know
anything about any of the languages
which is different to for example code
to comment ratios where you need to know
if you have 370 languages how do the
comments look like in each one of them
so we applied nearly duplication and we
released both the versions of the data
set
um on on the hanging face hub
um so people who don't trust our
immunization pipeline or have other
ideas they they're still free to do so
so that's essentially the the data set
uh that we built and we continue
developing
um
hit
um these are two aspects of the data set
as I said you can check whether you're
in the data set we have a space on on
the Hub called Mi in the stack where you
can enter your GitHub username and you
can see on the right for example what
happens when I enter my username I have
like five repositories and there some of
them are just Forex I didn't I didn't
invent data sets or the Transformers
Library
um but I can opt out so I can then open
an issue on a repository and then in the
next iterations those repositories will
be gone from the data set
one thing that we did was which was kind
of interesting is we wanted to figure
out like why do people want to opt out
and we did a little bit of like
Community study and they're like various
very different
attitudes towards having such a data set
so some people believe such a data set
should be opt-in by default not opt out
that makes it a little bit infeasible
for us if we want to have an opt-in data
set
at the beginning we weren't popular
we're still not very popular so it's
hard for us to reach enough people to
get like an opt-in data set that's large
enough hopefully uh maybe in the future
uh something like that is possible
um it's unfair to use my data set
without compensation as I said pii is a
concern but also like finally left some
people message us and said like my code
is very low quality I don't want you to
train on it it's too bad
it's like uh do you really want to train
on my Portuguese essay I wrote like 30
years ago it's like yeah why not
and some people are just a little bit
unsure like what we're doing is actually
the right thing and
but interesting not that many people
want to opt out and uh Jennifer daying
did a little bit of community research
and what's interesting is like people
don't necessarily want to opt out but
they want to have an option to opt out
and they want to have a way of checking
whether they're in the data set but the
people who then actually feel strongly
about opting out are are not that many
so enough about the data set side to the
exciting part training a model which is
only like the past the last few weeks of
a project but uh yeah star coder was the
result so we wanted to train a large
language model
um on that data set and we didn't take
the stack as it is we filtered it a
little bit further we also released the
stack as like a research object so
artifact other people can do other
things with it
but we applied even stronger near the
duplication that was a little bit of a
risk we weren't quite sure if that would
pay off but
the design is very good
we also did more language selection so
there is 370 languages and there's
always a question about around like how
much capacity does a language model have
to learn like different languages so
maybe if you train on 370 languages you
actually get verse on on the main
languages that you're interested in so
we were a little bit in the middle we
trained on almost 90 languages and
excluded a lot of languages that are
more like config files or or data
um one thing that we added on top of the
code which we thought would hopefully
help with the the understanding of code
especially like in combination with
natural language is GitHub issues which
are essentially conversations around
code git commits which if you filter
them right can have like meaningful
instructions how to modify code there
are also a lot of bad commit messages
like update fix which which are not so
uh useful and we filtered like very
heavily I think we started with four
terabyte and we ended up with 30
gigabytes
yeah
and another thing that we added was
Jupiter notebooks so we added them in
two forms one we just parsed them to to
Python scripts essentially and the other
thing is we did was like format them in
a structured way where you essentially
have like a code a markdown you have
code and you have the cell output
and retrained on that as well
um
one thing a lot of people want to always
get away from me including is like
actually looking at the data because
it's like in a sense boring you
sometimes find funny things like we
looked for curses in code and there's
like definitely interesting ways of
commenting your code
but we did a little bit of like a
community effort where we looked at 100
examples at least for every file
extension that we included in the data
uh in the training
um and we had I think around three four
hundred extensions so it was like a
significant enough a significant amount
of data that we had to look at
um and it helps if you have like a few
hundred people in the community uh to do
that and they got very excited about it
so we added like more filters
um to the
to the pre-processing
and finally one thing that's quite hard
to do is removing pii in code there are
not that many
data sets for piin code I mean they're
data sets for natural language and pii
in natural language so what we had to do
is actually annotate a data set
ourselves we had a company help us with
that so we built the data set with pii
and code we built a model to detect pii
and code we actually also pre-trained an
encoder model just to then train a pii
encoder and then we applied that to the
whole data set which also took like
quite a while to run a Transformer over
like a few terabytes of data
um but it works quite well if you ask
the model like who invented the light
bulb it would say the light bulb was
invented by name so that's good
and then you come to the question of
like you you have a big data set it's
hopefully fairly clean how do you best
train it like what model should you pick
and instead of like aiming for a model
that will like perform best on
benchmarks we also try to think a little
bit about like what will the user want
from a model they don't only want like a
model that gets a very high score on
benchmarks but they want a usable model
all the people have to deploy them you
don't want to make them cry so we try to
think a little bit about how can we make
that efficient and one thing is not
training the largest model that you can
maybe train a slightly smaller model but
train it a little bit for longer as I
said I'm going to talk a little bit more
about that so we only only train the 50
billion parameter model
we want to make sure that generating
with the model is fairly cheap and
there's a cool technique called
multi-career retention and starcoder is
the first I think open source model that
used that technique but I think since
then almost every architecture or every
new model that was released uses
multi-career attention because it's
quite nice when you first use it almost
uses no memory when you generate
and another thing that like the closed
models started to have like a while ago
and the opened open source model lack a
bit is long context like for a long time
the the longest context you could get in
an open model was like a thousand or
three thousand tokens
um and with flash attention you can
actually quite
reasonably scale it to 8 000 tokens
which is what we did
finally when especially when you
generate code it's quite important that
you can look uh before where you want to
complete and after because in natural
language most of the time the flow is
from left to right or from top to bottom
or at least in One Direction but when
you write code very often like a
function or a class can be defined
further Below in your code and if you
have a model that can only look to the
left it has a disadvantage
and there's a cool technique which
allows Auto regressive model to look on
the right it's called fill in the middle
very essentially just like parse the
inputs a bit and you put like the the
thing that comes next before so the
model can generate like what comes in
between
and you can get it for almost for free
in terms of like performance
foreign
and that's what we did we had the
architecture figured out so we started
to train
um we used the hacking phase cluster to
train this model we used 500 gpus for
roughly three four weeks
we had to distribute the model you can't
fit it on a single GPU for pre-training
so the TPP and DP for those who don't
know are like different ways of sharding
the model pipeline parallelism is
essential PP is pipeline parallelism so
essentially you distribute layers across
gpus TP is tensor parallelism very short
and one layer or one operation across
gpus and DP is data parallelism where
you um you essentially create replicas
of your model and you train in parallel
and we train for one trillion tokens
which is very similar to what the Llama
models did the Llama 2 models trained
for a little bit longer and we used our
own Fork of Megatron to do it which
included multi-career attention and
Flash attention
and as you can see the training was
quite smooth
um we didn't have any divergences
um as other people have experienced I
don't know if anybody ever looked at
like the opt logbook from Facebook where
they trained the large language models
it's 100 pages long with all kinds of
tricks like switching the optimizer in
between and like rewinding for 100 steps
and then going back we didn't have to do
anything of these things the reason the
the plot is multi-colored is that we
have Hardware failures so sometimes a no
goes down and we have to restart but I
think half of the time it was automatic
and the other half it was a voluntary
very new some note was fishy and we just
restarted it
but besides that we didn't have to do
much babysitting
and we built two models so start coded
base is essentially the model I just
talked about it's trained on 80
languages for 1 trillion tokens
since most benchmarks are in place and
we thought let's build a model that's
strong in python as well just to show
like how good you can get if you train a
little bit longer just 30 billion tokens
so three percent of the pre-training
budget uh on python to see how much you
can improve
and this is a devaluation so human eval
is one of the classic evaluations for
code models it's essentially you get a
function name and you get the doc string
and the task of the model is to complete
the function the nice thing is in that
Benchmark you also get unit tests so you
can actually test whether the
generations were correct you don't have
to do uh like these annoying scores in
NLP like blue scores so that don't
really tell you whether you're correct
which is even worse in code so we can
actually execute unit tests and the the
rate the numbers that you see here are
essentially the the Pass rates for I
think 160
programming challenges
and you can see a lot of Open Source
models like llama they're not
particularly good at coding because they
didn't train much on code you can also
see some of the closed Source models
like Palm or one one that's interesting
is code Cushman it's probably the model
that was used in copilot at the very
beginning nobody really knows because it
was never disclosed but
based on some reverse engineering
probably Cushman was initially a
co-pilot
so you can see very competitive with
those
and one thing that was quite interesting
there was a failure mode in our model
where it refused to answer the the
questions so rather than giving us the
solution to the function it would just
say the solution should go here and it
would stop and probably that came from
the fact that like lots of code on
GitHub has exercises where the solution
is just like a placeholder
and we fix this with a little prompt
hack so we use prefixes during
pre-training so you can add the file
name for example at the beginning so the
model knows what language it is but you
can also then specify as we did like
this is the solution this is not the
exercise you should you should really
write something here and then we try to
like further uh imprint that on the
model by adding a comment at the
beginning it's like here is the correct
solution not just a placeholder and one
thing that's interesting you see the
numbers went up by from 33 to 40 percent
just adding that little prompt
along with the model we also released an
extension because most people don't want
to play with the model in some
uh sandbox they want to actually use it
for coding so we have a vs code
extension
that's not so unusual I think most
people by now have like seen uh co-pilot
and maybe have tried it one thing we
added on top is a membership test
so a few collaborators worked on a very
fast membership test so it you can give
it a piece of code and it can tell you
like in a millisecond whether that piece
of code was in the pre-training data and
you can see here the the thing that's
read underlined that's a one-to-one
copied from the pre-training data so
that already gives the user some
information where that code came from
in addition to that at the bottom you
get a link to a full text search index
so you can copy paste that and you can
put it in the full text search and you
can see all the files that were in the
pre-training data what licenses they had
and who they belong to because even if
you use permissively license code you're
not allowed to just like copy paste
without attribution in principle you
should attribute the code you you copy
and so we try to provide the tools to do
that
um since then there have been like uh
more plugins by the community there's a
Jupiter plug-in there's a vim and emacs
plugin there's an alternative vs code
and checkbrains integration from a
startup calls refactor
um one thing that's quite funny about
the Jupiter
mode of the model since we trained on
code cells and their output we can
actually abuse the model as a python
interpreter we can force it to predict
what a cell would do which is quite fun
and also the the star coder family so to
say has a has been extended a bit I
talked about star coded base that's in
the center and star coder that has been
trained a bit more on python
but because we saw the model is not only
very good I only showed like one
Benchmark but we had like 10 15
benchmarks in the paper one thing that's
it's quite good at even compared to like
very big models is reasoning so even on
a legal reasoning Benchmark the model is
quite competitive if some of the largest
closed Source model so we thought but
it's not that great at text I mean it
can generate text but it's not great so
we thought let's train it a little bit
more with natural text as well that's
dark coder Plus
and for both star code base and star
coded plus we trained an instruction
version of the model that you can
explicitly uh talk to so because these
days most people are not excited that
excited anymore about code or language
models they want to instruction tune
models or chat models because you you
want to talk to them and just the base
model is not very good at like following
instructions
maybe just a small side note one thing
that was quite surprising is that even
without the instruction tuning you can
get the model to talk
um so one thing we tried is there has
been a prompt from anthropic called the
HHH prompt it's the helpful harmless and
honest prompt and it's just like a long
list of examples of a conversation and
we kind of adapted that to more like we
call it a TA prompt the technical
assistant prompt that's more focused on
coding questions and answers and you can
see on the left it's just a Converse a
list of conversations between an
assistant and a human and if you prepend
that to the role model you can then talk
to it which was quite surprising when we
first tried it you have like a model
that has been trained to predict the
next token in code and suddenly you can
talk to it without any fine tuning and
for example on the right is an example
where I asked it what's give me a python
code that tells me what the weather in
Burn is and it wrote a piece of code
that did that
but of course we then also as I said
explicitly finds you in it to chat it's
much better that way and it is
especially better at like explaining the
the code it wrote so
um here is like an example where it's
asked to like write a piece of code that
concept prime numbers between 1 and 100
and then it also explains a bit at the
bottom like what the code actually does
um in the comment it also tries to
predict what the number is but it fails
um the
model is released under uh open rail
license it's not a an open source
license per se the main difference is
that it comes with use case restrictions
so for example you can't use the model
to extract pii we tried hard that you
can't do it but I'm sure like if people
try long enough they'll be able to still
get something out of it you're also not
allowed to for example generate malware
with the model under that license but
besides that you're free to like train
it on your own data you're free to use
it for commercial purposes
that's all good the main thing is
ethical use case restrictions
how are we for time I have a few minutes
um cool yeah I just want to very briefly
talk about the chinchilla trap and harms
law harm is one of the collaborators in
big code and he did a interesting
analysis on the scaling loss who here
has heard of scaling laws for language
models
a few people so in very simple terms the
scaling loss give us like a recipe when
you have a certain amount of compute you
say I have a thousand gpus for a month
the scaling laws tell you what's the
best ratio of like model size and data
set size you should train on so maybe if
you have a thousand gpus for a month
maybe you should train like a 30 billion
parameter model on a trillion tokens
something like that so it's like a
recipe that tells you if I have that
much compute that that's the kind of
model I should train
anti-scaling laws have evolved a bit
initially there was a paper from openai
called like now called like Kaplan
scaling laws and they said like if you
scale you should scale the model five
times and you should scale the data two
times like if you get more compute and
that's kind of the recipe for cheap D3
it was 170 billion parameter model
trained on 300 billion tokens
a year after uh deepmind did a study
around the model they called chinchilla
and they derived new scaling laws they
found some issues with the first
iteration and they found actually you
should train for longer
um and so chinchilla is a 65 billion
parameter model trained for 1.6 trillion
tokens
and now very recently people have
figured out like actually being compute
optimal in the sense of like chinchilla
or the scale uh this is the original
scaling loss it's not the thing that you
want because those scaling laws give you
a recipe for
what's the model you want to train to
get the best performance on a benchmark
but it ignores completely how much
you're going to pay to put that in
production it's like if you train 170
billion parameter model it's going to be
very expensive to run that so if you can
train a smaller model maybe you want to
do that and it seems like industry has
caught up to that a bit llama is much
smaller and trained for even longer
compared to its size
and what harm did that's why we call it
like Harm's law is he took the
chinchilla scaling loss and it just like
looking at the equation a bit and
reformulated them so what you can see
here is essentially this chinchilla
optimal Point that's what the chinchilla
tells you to do it's like you want to
train a model at 0.1
but that Optimum is actually quite flat
so the the xdy axis the x-axis tells you
like the model size compared to
chinchilla optimal the y-axis tells you
how much compute you're going to pay if
you want to match the optimal model
so you can see it's very flat if you go
left and you train a model or that's
only 75 percent of its size you only pay
a few percent uh compute overhead uh
most people would be happy to pay that
to uh to save a little bit of money at
inference time as you go to the left at
some point you're going to hit a wall
it's going to go up very steeply but
even like 100 compute overhead might be
totally fine for a model like chat CPT
that's now deployed for hundreds of
millions of users and probably uh
bleeding open AI quite a bit so you want
to train models more on the left side
rather on the than than at the optimal
point or on the right hand side and the
the the Green Point is llama 2 at the 7
billion scale which you can see is like
in that nice region where you uh
actually get like a lot of inference
saving and you don't pay that much but
the 70b Lamar model is actually a little
bit more on the right hand side
you can't play that game infinitely
because you don't have infinite data and
scaling smaller models gets much harder
so training a very small model on a
thousand gpus is much harder than
training a large model on a thousand
CPUs that's why not everybody is like
all the time on the left side but if you
can you want to be there
and now I have a little bit of time left
I think to answer a few questions
[Applause]
thanks very much for the talk
um I have two quick questions so the
first one is uh I think you showed your
evaluation comparison with other models
and you also mentioned that you did a
bit of prompting in order for it to work
so did you do a prompting during
training
so you also did prompting during
training uh did you no no so so the the
prompting that we did is more like the
things that the model naturally saw
during pre-training
uh
here
um so you see like the prompt the the
first line which the file name that's
how we pre-train so we sometimes prepend
the file name during pre-training and
the second line is just the code comment
in Python so that's more like prompting
in the sense like the natural uh code
comments that the model would see
aha I see and for other models you don't
do prompting at all we tried it for for
a few models but it didn't work uh that
well but also we didn't have time to
like trying to optimize all the other
models we saw that weakness and we
reported both numbers for fairness so
the prompted one and the unprompted one
ah I see yeah the reason why I asked
because uh sometimes you find those
larger language models prompting and
non-prompting is totally a different
story yeah yeah I see and for the second
question uh Sarah you mentioned uh
attached upon the like an amount of data
and it really matters a lot uh I wanna
um so there is a recent paper from
Microsoft there like textbook is all you
need so they really put a lot of
emphasis on the quality of the data and
they they argue that you know the
quantity doesn't matter that much and as
long as you really curate you know high
quality data and it works so I wonder
what's your understand on this yeah yeah
I mean that's definitely true it's like
quantity is always quality is always
better than quantity but it's hard to
get to Quality if you start with low
quantity in the first place so I showed
like the stack is 6.4 terabytes
um the actual data we trained on is 250
gigabytes
so we got rid of a lot of data along the
way no actually actually that's not true
I think it's 600 gigabytes but still
like a factor of 10 of data that we got
rid of
um there's also a nice paper from some
some people at targeting face and other
institutions about repeating data
because when you run out the the other
natural thing you can do is like train
two epochs right
and they did some ablation to see like
how far can you push that and it seems
like if you nearly duplicate well so you
get rid of like as much duplication as
possible you can train five times
before you see before you notice like a
performance degradation
which is always a little bit funny in my
head you first like to duplicate and
then you duplicate again but it's a
little bit about like you don't want to
have the natural duplication which is
like a million config files
but you want to have like diversity so
you get rid of those and then you
duplicate like uniformly about around
like what you have left
thank you yeah yeah you're welcome
also as a intermediate comment I have
like tons of stickers and if anybody
wants one
for a long time
thanks a lot for having me
now we would have two short
announcements to make and the first one
by Joel
I think you don't I guess I can go on
without it um so the first thing I want
to announce
um or advertise is on the 21st of
September this is going to be the
sixth edition of The Swiss pageant
Summit so a very large
conference on python it's going to be
held at the
University of applied sciences in the
repossil so you should check out the
website at the moment we still have
early bird tickets and soonish we're
going to release the program and we're
going to increase the price so now is a
good time to get a cheap ticket
second announcement
cool let
now we is to click alone yes it is yeah
awesome Edo do you want to come up as
well
cool
um
come on up
so
we
awesome
uh because he gets the credit for
starting the thing uh so
we have recently started python Sprint
here in Zurich and it's a Meetup that is
all about contributing to open source
and giving back to the community like I
guess many of you will be practitioners
that use the amazing open source
libraries that
folks put a lot of work in in your
like in your job or maybe your spare
time as well
um and so yeah if if you looking for
ways to give back and help out those
maintainers that often don't get paid
then come along to python sprints
we've had one Sprint so far we we're
planning another one uh for after the
summer break probably September stay
tuned uh in the meantime if you want to
get notified we have a Meetup Group uh
which you join
we have a Twitter
and uh like a landing page as well uh on
on GitHub
and uh edit anything you want to add
come and join us
awesome
yeah so the the previous one we were
contributing to the scikit-learn but uh
yeah there's plenty of other projects
and obviously
um happy to take suggestions and
important if you know maintainers that
are based in Switzerland we would like
please let us know
and then we can run more events
cool if we skip to the I do want to make
another super quick plug
um if you want to give back even more
so num focus is the not-for-profit that
is behind Pi data
and num Focus actually supports like
open source projects and uh the packages
that that we all use every day
also financially so they uh like they
provide scholarships for maintainers and
other support and these kind of things
so if you or even better ask your boss
if your company would consider
sponsoring
non-focus takes tax deductible donations
and there's a couple of other ways to
contribute so if you
feel so inclined check numfocus.org
where you can read much more
awesome I'll hand
it back to a very smooth transition uh
thank you thank you Florian and with
that we're at the end the last few words
that I would like to address is
um thanks so much lovely Ben who's
sitting over there who made all of this
possible please give a warm Applause
there
yeah
um also thanks a lot to the to the
friendly faces behind behind the desk uh
your your support is much appreciated
and necessary thanks so much to you too
oh welcome for the uh an Applause for
them as well please
and then with that we're at the end uh
if you like this
um consider getting a part of this
consider helping us organize uh
contribute with talks maybe your
employer would like to host us at some
point for for a future Edition uh maybe
help us organize and also if you did not
like it try to make us better maybe
that'd be great if you could help us out
we don't have the next Edition schedule
just yet but we're in the process of
doing that just just check out our media
page and stay tuned uh thanks for coming
and have a lovely evening everyone
yeah and just just to clarify so uh like
we're not going to kick you out if you
want to chat more to the speakers to the
organizers amongst yourselves we we have
this room and there's a bit of like the
outside space like the atrium space so
you can hang around uh like as long as
you like like I think probably 10 we
might have a hot stop but uh yeah please
hang around and network as they say
thank you thank you
[Applause]
foreign